hi my name is Alan Glickenhaus I'm the
IBM API business strategist and today
I'd like to talk to you about API use
cases one of the things that I spend a
lot of time with clients discussing I
thought we'd start with some simple use
cases under methodology and then talk to
where this might go over time as we
develop new business models so let's
start simple a lot of times when I do
talk to clients and I'll introduce the
methodology next the they start to jump
immediately to some of the more complex
situations and really that's not what
you're going to do you're going to start
with some simple scenarios so let's
introduce the methodology and then we'll
show some simple use cases that you can
start with in your industry so from a
methodology perspective I have thought
of six categories of areas that I think
about when I'm thinking about what API
is might be applicable to your
particular industry we are on this slide
three of on the next the first one is
mobile or internal development almost
they're all companies start with that
and if you think about what you're going
to do with your mobile app there are
three types of information that you
might make available the first is
generic information so this is common
information that anyone who is using
your mobile app would get the same
answers things like where you located
whether your interest rates if you're a
bank what kind of accounts do you have
if you're a retailer what kind of
products do you have things like that
it's the same list for everybody the
next category would be things like that
are specific to an individual customer
so what does your account balance is
going to be different for each
individual and finally we might look at
how the mobile device itself can be
taken advantage of in conjunction with
the api's so things like your GPS
coordinate so the camera could be used
in conjunction with the API is to
provide a good solution second category
is partnering and we think first about
the partners that we already have and
what kinds of information we're sharing
with the partners already and then one
of the big areas of API growth is in
partner onboarding so if you think about
what goes into bringing a partner on
board today for every partner that you
work with you after you agree that you
will be partners you'll start to
introduce
your AP your interfaces to them it might
be a web service interface before you're
using AP is and that could be rather
complex and you need to set up the
security around that for that individual
partner teach them how to use the the
soap interface for the web service and
get them all set up and that takes
effort on your part and on the part of
the partner and when you're done you
have one partner on board what we'd like
to do with API is is make the API
self-sufficient so that the partner can
come to the developer portal find the
api's sign-on and consume those api's
without any effort on your part and very
little learning on their side you've
already done the setup for the security
and the testing and so on so it should
work very well the third category is
public and here we start to think about
comparison apps whether other parts of
the industry may be doing comparison
between what you offer in your
competition it could also be things that
you might make available through others
that are what I call the industry next
door so we'll get into that a little bit
more when I show the examples but other
industries that might send customers to
you the next category is social
obviously there's a lot going on in
social media today we want to take
advantage of that so we start to think
about things that might be as simple as
direct references to your company
whether positive or negative or other
things that people are talking about on
social media that you can take advantage
of and so those will be some of the
things that we'll think about there from
a device perspective we'll talk about
what devices might be taken advantage of
and how those devices can work with your
company and and provide information to
you or get information from you to deal
with the client directly the other thing
which I mentioned not that it's going to
be a direct seller for why you'll use AP
is but if you think about what we've
done with the user interface technology
over decades every time we come out with
a new user interface whether that was
the web or now mobile and whatever is
going to happen after this we always
have to go back to those back-end
systems and tell the folks okay now you
need to support the web now you need to
support mobile well once we have API is
making the data available without
context of an individual user interface
whatever the next interface is going to
be after mobile or tablets that could be
glasses it could be you know something
that projects on the screen whatever it
may be I don't have to go back to the
back end people because we're already
making that information available
through the API and then the final
category and probably one of the most
important is valuable data every company
is collecting valuable data on your
clients about your what your business is
doing and a certain subset of the
population inside the company is getting
access to that data through api's we can
make that data available to a larger
audience inside your company and get
more value out of the data were
collecting finally we might also have a
monetization opportunity to sell that
data at the third parties and make some
additional revenue so let's get into
some of the examples and I said we're
going to start simple right so we're not
going to think of complicated things
when we think about the mobile internal
development examples in this case are
the account types that a bank might
offer the product list that retailer
might have what kind of insurance plans
or telecommunications plans often on
your website you have prices and really
a good way to think about this is what
are you doing on your website today
those are the kind of things you're
probably going to want to do on your
mobile app and so those are examples of
basic generic information and then when
we think about the customer specific
information it might be that they're
going to place an order with you and
what is the order status or what's their
account balance in the bank and do they
want to transfer funds all these things
have to do with individual customers and
we need to qualify who they are and
secure that and make sure that they're
only seeing their information so all the
industries will have things about that
as well
and then finally using the mobile device
itself in conjunction with the api's we
might find the nearest ATM right so to
do that I need to know where you are and
so your GPS coordinates from the phone
can help with that or where's the
nearest branch or store or whatever
you're looking for if this is an
insurance situation maybe we're going to
submit a picture of a car accident as
part of the claim or deposit a check and
of course mobile wallet for payments is
another big area partnering so think
about the kind of information we're
sharing with partners already what is
the inventory status
we need to reorder the additional
additional goods in the commercial
banking area we think about the large
companies that we're supporting as
partners and so what we want to do is
make available the api's so that the
commercial so that the banking customers
can integrate the API is directly with
the bank and make this part of their
business processes and that really
solidifies the relationship between the
bank and the particular company part
suppliers might make available API so
that people can order from them and
repair places can make available manuals
or you know the ability to request a
repair for something that they have
going on in the automotive space options
and add-ons and having that be
interoperable across multiple different
vendors is important and making API is
available for that purposes is the
common thing that people will do and
then in the government space things like
sharing information across agencies so
they are your partner agencies and they
need a certain subset of the information
inside your enterprise but not
everything and we can make that
available on a case-by-case basis
through a pis and then think about
smarter cities and if there's a
situation that occurs and we want to
coordinate emergency services coming to
a particular situation and I'll talk
more about that when I get to some of
the advanced scenarios and then finally
platform services are there things that
your company does that maybe others can
take advantage of billing hosting
accounting things like that where other
companies can come in to you and take
advantage of this even having nothing to
do with the industry that you're in the
next category is public and so here
we're talking about the comparison apps
so if you want to be involved in a
comparison if you're not going to want
to be involved like a virus and then
nobody's going to buy from you because
they're using the comparison app you're
not there so you'll probably want to be
part of that and making API is available
that show your products your pricing and
the availability can help people buy
from you and then finally that industry
next door that I mentioned and this is
key when we start to think about
reaching new markets reaching new
customers and getting new new customers
for our particular company think about
what other industries people are dealing
with that need what you provide so if
you're a bank
people who are buying a car need a car
loan people who are needing uh buying a
home need a mortgage or people that are
planning for retirement need financial
information so what are the other things
that people do that need banking and
those are the industries that you want
to target for your AP is and make them
available for government think about job
placement and education and there's many
many more health and fitness for
insurance or healthcare and finally for
retail and travel vacation birthday and
holiday industry might send customers to
you for social and Big Data obviously if
someone mentions your company directly
on social media they might be seeing
something positive about your company
and you want to capture that and retweet
it get that information out there if
they're saying something negative about
your company you want to address that
immediately before the word spreads and
things get out of hand so social
interactions are very big in fact social
api's are the most common way that
people interact with social media it's
not a web interface or a mobile
interface it's through through api's
opportunity identification you might
notice that some people are talking
about particular things on social media
so there's certain keywords that you can
key on maybe somebody's talking about
going on vacation and you're a retailer
and you can sell them something in that
area or maybe you're a travel company
that can help them find a rental car or
a hotel in the area that they're going
to and then participating in interest
groups as well is something that you can
do to have a presence and get your
advertising out there and also just pop
populating social media with what you're
doing as a company and getting involved
one of the things I've heard about is
insurance companies getting involved in
this way because so much of dealing with
insurance companies is always in a
negative situation when you're either
paying them or you have a claim they
want to get out there and show you that
they're doing good things for the
community as well
device integration think about the
devices it's not always obvious that
something is a device not everything is
a monitor or a sensor or something like
that cameras can be devices appliances
or devices ATMs cars there are many
things that are devices and we can share
information from the
back into the enterprise and take action
on that or send commands out to the
device like if it's a camera to Japan in
a particular direction or focus in on
something and so so those are all things
that we can do as well I'll come up with
a scenario that in the more Advanced
section on ATMs that will show you some
of the kind of futuristic things that we
might do in this space as well and then
that valuable data category so we're
going to get access to this data for a
larger audience inside the enterprise
that has tremendous value and you can
also then sell aggregated data on
clients to third parties and make that
available or if clients opt into
marketing you might sell specific
information on them to third parties if
they choose to opt in to be marketed to
the other thing I've talked like some
companies about whether it's a connected
car a telecommunications company as
people are driving around the city their
route to work can be detected and you
might sell that in aggregate to third
parties for marketing to particular
audiences and then finally in the
government space there's a lot of open
data initiatives that require access to
data and api's are a very good way to do
that as well so that's that's where we
are most companies are going to start
with that and I really encourage you to
start simple don't don't think of
immediately of doing the more
complicated things will get there over
time but I do want to show you where we
can go over time so I've got a couple of
scenarios and these are going to be more
eco system type scenarios things that
will involve multiple industries working
together so these are scenario based and
I'll just call out a couple of examples
here so let's say we have a connected
car and it's been in an accident and the
airbags have been deployed and there's
some possible need for some assistance
here if it's a very severe accident the
car might be able to know that and
immediately call for accident if it's
not sure maybe an alert is raised to the
drivers mobile phone and they can either
say yes they need help or if they don't
reply that might be an indication that
they need help as well and a call can be
put out to emergency services that could
be an ambulance it could be fire police
the car sensors might determine which
ones of those are required and
if there's a fire concerned calling the
fire department is well the insurance
data could be collected probably not the
most important thing to deliver right
away but we could certainly collect that
and make that available through an API
later and then all the things that are
going on around that accident so an
alert can be issued so that other cars
can understand that an accident has
occurred in a particular place the
traffic apps that they're using to be
made aware of this accident and can
assess what impact that's having on the
traffic and whether or not they need to
move around on a different route
hospitals may be notified that there's
certain injuries that might be coming in
and if there's damage to the
infrastructure a case can be open so you
see here this is not just one industry
involved these API is are going to be
talking to too many different industries
government health care insurance auto
social media all kinds of things can
happen based on one particular scenario
and so it's not going to be just one
party that's interested but a whole
ecosystem supporting the help that needs
to be given to a particular person
that's been in an accident next scenario
a computer computer is going home from
work at the end of the day they're going
by train they get to the train station
and they see that their train is running
ten minutes late they are a banking
customer and that Bank happens to have
an ATM at the station and they have
opted in to being marketed to for
selected products that they're that they
like and so they have near-field
communication on on their phone and the
ATM recognizes that they're in the area
and it starts to put together some
opportunity to market to this particular
person so the weather api's might be
used to determine that it's an extremely
hot day and this person's train is
running come in it's late so what we're
going to do is push an advertisement to
that customer of the bank for their
favorite ice cream that's on sale at
retailer they're at the train station
and we're going to give them a 10%
discount if they buy in the next ten
minutes which happens to be the delay of
the train right so all this goes
together we then push that advertisement
to them to the customer the customer
goes into the retailer shows the
advertisement on their phone and the
retailer will make money the consumer
packaged goods company
that's selling the ice cream will make
more money and the bank will get
compensated for part of the transaction
for identifying the customer and getting
that customer to come into the store so
again an ecosystem kind of relationship
between banks retails consumer packaged
goods all working together with weather
API is involved as well
last example a huge winter storm is
predicted and weather API is attracting
the the severity of the storm and the
path of the storm and interested parties
who are trying to figure out how they're
going to get home at the end of their
day are starting to get notified that
this storm is coming in and so the
information from the weather API is is
put together with their profile
information that will tell them you know
that knows what their typical work hours
are what their route home is and what
the path of the storm is through the
weather API is and plan what possible
actions they might take whether that's
leaving early or taking a different
route and so on so the individuals can
choose to act and leave work status
updates can be communicated directly to
them through their mobile phone or
better yet through their connected car
so that they're not dealing with their
mobile while they're driving in the
storm and then alternate routing can
happen to take place if necessary so
that they can get to where they're
trying to go if there are road closures
things like that because maybe the
travel accident scenario that we talked
before they would get notified and be
able to move around that in a more
smooth fashion and then in addition we
can start pushing the status updates out
to social media so that others can see
what's going on with the road conditions
and the road clearing estimates so these
three examples are just examples of
multiple industries working together in
an ecosystem and where this API economy
is going to go over time these are not
the first scenarios that you're going to
work on as a company so start with those
simple scenarios and work forward from
there
I've written lots of blogs on this topic
best place to start is on the URL at the
top of this page this is a blog that
I've written on API use cases for every
industry and if you start here you get
some good recommendations that apply
across industries including the idea of
looking at what other industries are
that blog will link to 20 different
industry specific blogs that I've
written with the use cases in the six
categories that I mentioned earlier so
you can get some sample use cases in
your specific industry for for what you
might do to start off with and maybe
some advanced scenarios as well so this
is again a very hot topic one of the
things that businesses really need to
think about as they start to move into
the API economy and hopefully these
blogs in this video will help you move
forward successfully